le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
chaque année à la réunion de nombreuses
familles ne peuvent pas partir en
vacances
la plupart du temps parce qu'elles ne
trouvent pas d'hébergement dans leurs
moyens c'est pourquoi le département a
signé un partenariat avec la caf
permettant à certains bénéficiaires de
partir en vacances dans des structures
de villégiature la famille renée ainsi
pu passer une semaine au village de
corail géré par le département à la
saline les bains
[Musique]
au plus bas tant qu'on est ici j'ai vu
l'évolution de village ça fait du bien
de venir ici parce qu'on ne sait pas
nuit on oublie tout comment la maison là
beaucoup de choses à faire on est bien
ses enfants familles il va plein show
d'activité pour sonia et ses trois
enfants
le village corail est devenu un rendez
vous incontournable des soirées karaoké
des soirées organisées par les
animateurs de l'hôtel et a pris aussi à
le bas par les glaces après la pipe ou
la plage et après ça j après tout le
soleil donc on s'ennuie pas si ces
vacances sont possibles pour la famille
renée c'est grâce au dispositif a t elle
géré par lagaf et qui permet la prise en
charge des frais d'hébergement au
village de corail dans le dispositif va
t elle veut dire est d'autant livre ce
dispositif s'adresse aux familles
allocataires de la caf ayant au moins un
enfant est en conscient familial
inférieur à 650 euros
et ces familles peuvent bénéficier dans
ce jour soit en demi pension
donc petit déjeuner dîner sans
hébergement seul c'est une aide qui leur
permet d'avoir des vacances à prix
réduit pour une semaine avec ses trois
enfants et son mari
sonia n'a eu qu'à débourser 125 euros le
dossier disponible directement au
village de corail peut également être
téléchargé sur le site de la caf pour
les papiers c'est internet
on le remplit en envoyant dans le
village corail et il renvoie polak à la
cave une jeune qui vont payer une partie
et nous on paie la différence en 2016
2836 foyers ont pu séjourner au village
de corey grâce au dispositif a t elle
l'objectif pour le département
évidemment de favoriser des vacances
pour tous sachant que la priorité
l'une des priorités du département reste
le social avec ce bâtiment ce dispositif
ce village on peut faire du tourisme
social et faire profiter aux familles
auraient lyonnaise est plus modeste des
vacances au bord de la mer pieds dans
l'eau
[Musique]
avec la proche du cyclone berg ita la
famille renée a dû écourter son séjour
d'une journée
ce n'est que partie remise pour sonia
qui a déjà repris rendez vous pour
l'année prochaine
[Musique]
géré par le département
le village corail fait partie des cinq
lieux de la réunion concernés par le
dispositif des d'autant libre disponible
uniquement lors des périodes de vacances
scolaires le village propose un séjour
en demi pension ou en hébergement seul
avec des tarifs à prix réduits pour les
familles nombreuses
l'aide aux temps libres s'adresse aux
familles ayant un quotient familial
inférieur à 650 euros
la prise de contact peut être prise
depuis l'accueil du village corail ou
par le biais du site internet de la caf
jusqu'à 80% du prix du séjour peut être
prise en charge
pour plus d'informations rendez vous sur
le site du département sur www.cc 9 7 4
pour 1 fr
[Musique]